I'm gonna take a wild guess the Jim
Norton is [ __ ] oh yeah big [ __ ] I
would imagine that but Roland's
photographing it finally the payback
tables of turn mark Normand is here
around Bennington is here we're just
talking about the Voss roast if we still
encourage people to buy yesterday Voss
took his shirt off on the show promising
and we promised him that people would
buy the roast if he took his shirt off
and people did I saw a bunch of you guys
sending Voss and Bonnie stuffed with the
receipt from you buying the thing the
roasted at Voss roast com it looks
amazing 471 he that's why we try to get
him to take his shirt off every times
yeah Wow well done I'll get some new
jeans though those things are a little
tattered yeah that's the cool but you
mark did you see the roast I popped in
on a little bit it was amazing yeah
Quinn was murdering when I was there and
then I had to run but yeah I can't wait
to buy it yeah I I came that was
supposed to be the party the birthday
party after and the time that I got
there for the party there was still like
four or five people to go and I'm like
everybody was killing and like big J was
going last that I'm like how [ __ ] man
this room might be left out he [ __ ]
destroys and then I'm like oh poor Voss
he's got to follow all this after three
hours Voss destroys yeah
yeah and Voss was saying yesterday that
he was nervous going up there yeah but
his saving grace was that Kumi has
started heckling him from the audience
and I was like 10 feet away Anthony was
annihilated that night yeah remember it
but it was very funny boss felt really
good about it and he did he did confirm
that he left that in the Edit he
absolutely absolutely yeah he attacked
qu me like a angry black woman yeah yeah
we were talking about Florentine and the
reason why his set was so good and I
think the reason is that was so good was
just because of how much he was getting
annihilated leading up to it I'm talking
about his exes his accident cheated on
him the ex that killed herself like all
this stuff and you have kind of had this
feeling of
see how Florentines good I don't see how
any person would come back from all this
right and he just comes up in effortless
effort lystie destroys everybody on this
day he's a killer he was great he was
amazing on the road yeah he's he's
hitting Jim I just treated myself to a
little [ __ ] the back door you like yeah
like you know what why holding it let's
go sit down and relax one stall taken
second time this week you've gone in for
a number one find out it was number two
I can't help you just stand there and
your system is kind of jostling around
I'm like you know what treat yourself
you're gonna have to go from urine all
over the toilet finished up in the
urinal I walk him back right into the
bowl look at that maybe you piss with
your pants around your ankles I always
do like a child yeah holy just an old
man in the [ __ ] gym with his pants
like down to mid thigh and I'm like what
the [ __ ] are you doing old man move
you're a grown-up yeah is that a [ __ ]
football game with a guy that I know and
he [ __ ] dropped his pants down like
that and there had to be 70 of us in the
[ __ ] men's room and he had his pants
down there was [ __ ] knees when I was
taking a piss why do people as the hell
I like the purpose of it right why am i
embarrassed cuz my friends doing that
Yeah right you can't get in like why you
look in right and it wasn't a goof it
was just this is what I do know we were
very well known in that town we had a
big radio show oh my god I would never
want my balls out why do you want your
balls out you have to shine Oh crazy
balls yeah oh yeah we were talking about
that I think real gross long one of them
is yeah okay my arms are wide apart as I
can make them Wow nice and tight good
for you yeah the doctor said you'd never
seen anything like it
that's because you do the kegels right
oh I don't do anything Wow why I have
some Swedish blood and that's very very
helpful
a nice tight bag way to match on it we
it's tighter when I have to poo
does it ever get that no no Jesus you
might have [ __ ] in your ball
yeah yeah no balls don't want to be
dangled on the toilet because they
probably know so they [ __ ] suck up to
protect themselves what a great call I
think my body runs hot and you're my
balls have to get away from the heat so
they hang low
in your medical opinion yeah the entire
reason why that organ is on the outside
yeah that's right that's why your balls
in the summer get [ __ ] Lucy and Lucy
goosy exactly Lucy yeah my balls are all
loosey goosey never that dive in the
ocean your balls just [ __ ] just shoot
into your toe Dottie so yeah it's like a
[ __ ] fright like I hope that [ __ ]
popped back down again well you're
getting jerked off in your balls are in
your body it looks like you have no nuts
that's would you like it more when it's
humiliating Yeah right
speaking female eiated did you see the
update on the on the kid who the thirty
year old the guy kicked out of his house
I did yeah he's doing well he has that
you remember the guy in Syracuse no you
didn't hear about the story that his
parents took him to court and had an
addicted yeah Wow yeah he's a good boy
so the guy yeah and then I believe
wasn't he pressing charges against his
parents yes for the stolen Legos disk
not they they got the leg goes back hey
did you get the Legos she's suing Best
Buy that's why yeah that's that's that's
in the update so this guy
listen Syracuse he's been with his
parents he's been having a tough time
moving out so his parents finally had
enough of him and they took him to court
and they had him evicted and the court
said you have to leave today which he
was like flabbergasted II didn't
understand that at all but he's been
living in an Airbnb and and working for
room and board
no the his parents said your honor he
looks like a white kid who's moved to
India now I would today today's the
today's the 21st all right by December
31st this kid hangs himself that's it
hopes there's my [ __ ] thing hold this
tape okay hold it Travis so that way he
put out if the police are just
acting murder rom Bennington is the
place to come I just know been through
this with people like Mike Rotundo
before what wasn't he a [ __ ] wrestler
or when our shyster very similar yes by
the way I text you guys I don't know if
you had a said I'm sorry about later
that was a rough no I didn't get that
tax but we've helped in my moment of
weakness
not that founder home you know what you
know seriously [ __ ] strange and
hilarious was that you that was tweeting
out now it will always be Vader time
know that was fuzzy
he literally sent me that text I could
pull it out it yeah he wrote I guess it
is Vader time that's great was a
wrestler named Vader he's at his Vader
time big van the big van Vader and he
passed away and a lot of wrestling fans
were tweeting out now it will always be
Vader time I see he was the guy who tore
up the year what's his thing he did he
was yet Mick Foley was wrestling him
when he got his ear torn off ah that's
right Paul Stanley that's right
look at that big boy never with him baby
no I was in the arena of the night that
Holyfield's uh [ __ ] here get bit off
when it turned into a madhouse
no one ever brings that up people went
running into the [ __ ] casino turning
over [ __ ] tables the [ __ ] shots
rang out the MGM ever mate yeah never
made the [ __ ] news huh why did people
go crazy like that uh we were just all
caught up in it anybody yeah they've
been a zero off people were furious you
know cuz people had money on it oh yeah
this was also like wow yes he took that
much off yeah a lot of cartilage gone oh
my god
and fights broke out all over like
people were so nice how much I don't
know have you ever been to a big price
point like that the [ __ ] tension is
through the roof oh really yeah I get so
much money on yeah yeah I think you guys
about to beat each other yeah I mean
sometimes it takes you back like when
you were in school and everybody we ran
out next to the bike racks to see the
fight that's the best moments of your
life yeah yeah adrenaline is pumping
just chaos everywhere I got my ass
kicked on
was a you know three o'clock by the yeah
oh no what happened by the bike I was
coming bad I panted Doug Benson and then
he pantsed me and then we got hands to
meet you you pull the pants down okay
and yeah so we had a we had a go at it
and he was like he was beaten by his
parents he was one of these like cabron
side of the track [ __ ] up kids so he
he had no shame or fear he was just like
I know all I know is violence right and
I was like eh you know cute douche so he
beat you up oh yeah
front everybody we embarrassed oh yeah
it's brutal it's not yeah it's like
Hardwick you can't live it down yeah you
can't no you just everyday you're all
you're the guy who got beat up but did
you get his name Mickey he was Irish did
you guys see each other after that oh
yeah we were cool and we made friends
but you know he would do he beat you up
and he knew it yeah but it was a close
fight I got a few in but he was just
vicious I mean the kid had bruises on
him from his uncle did you get into a
lot of fights I got knocked out pretty
good once how son I got well Mardi Gras
parade we got no fight with these
college kids I think I know this story
yeah really well I think you told me oh
yeah and then it all broke up and then I
was hanging out with you know later
talking to a girl and the girl goes was
this guy doing and I turn he was running
and he just hit me and I saw white
passed out and pissed myself that's cool
I woke up in a guy's lawn covered urine
and I woke up to my friends fighting
this guy did you find that girl yeah I
did actually
Wow urinate on yourself oh you should
have married her what a good egg yeah
she went sympathy [ __ ] oh that's awesome
look like for that for 49 years knocked
out one time when I was a kid a [ __ ]
grown man [ __ ] knocked me out why and
I wake up I'm on the hood of his car and
the [ __ ] guy that knocked me out was
waking me up alone wake up kid please
wake up
he was [ __ ] freaked out that you know
he was gonna go to jail for why he knock
you out you thought you were a hit you
with him no he punched me we were eating
ludes me and this buddy and these two
girls were out of the reservoir and we
rolled rockin like 14 or 15 when my
friend was 16 and he was driving like a
[ __ ] maniac
and
we just weren't aware of it we were just
like laughing and [ __ ] grabbin tits
and he [ __ ] smacked into this guy's
car so I'm in the backseat with this
other girl I look up and I see my friend
get knocked on the [ __ ] ground and I
just jump up and say hey you know I'm
[ __ ] running towards the fight and
that [ __ ] dude just clocks me you
know just clocks me and when you're
[ __ ] down doubt like that turtle
it's like you don't put your hands up
you don't mean like everything is you
know and for [ __ ] three days my
drawers look just like a [ __ ] yeah so
wait he wakes you up on the hood he's
panicking yeah he [ __ ] picks me up
carries me the hood of his car I was
like wake up wake up kid and I'm [ __ ]
I'm looking at the guy who just knocked
me out and what did he say when you woke
up he's like I got a [ __ ] temper I'm
sorry you are you know he was [ __ ]
apologizing his ass off Wow yeah he
brand are young yeah yeah that was a
[ __ ] baby face it was like yeah I got
in some shots too you know we did all
right no my [ __ ] hands he knocked
both your glasses off yeah that's that's
the thing like when you're younger like
that you don't take it personal right
like all my best friends we've fought
before we became friends in my
neighborhood we had a fight huh and then
we became buddies I guess if you fight
regularly probably not that embarrassing
when you lose one it's not what's to be
embarrassed about you're in a fight
right the [ __ ] point is and your dad
teaches this when you're a kid fight
enough that you're not the guy that's
easy to fight yeah what you want to do
is like oh it's not [ __ ] worth it to
take that kids money you know I mean
right is the one for a while yeah he's
gonna put up a fight so you a bully
we'll fight somebody that won't fight
right bully doesn't want to be in a good
fight you're trying to avoid it yeah
somebody looking to avoid a fight is
gonna give you their money right yeah
right yeah that's one thing I couldn't
fight not a tough guy but I I would
fight to good something yeah I don't
[ __ ] with him he'll scratch you hit a
watch I was always watching a subway
video recently and you know people like
these moments in life though like I two
guys [ __ ] fighting like in the subway
steps and the little guy was kind of the
big guy was are there
pressed up like against where the the
information booth is and the little guy
is like sneaky in and like I get a
couple shots in and the other guy bites
his face oh and he bit a piece of his
lip off Wow like that's what happened
like that's what real life is yeah movie
there's our two guys duking it out real
life is a guy wraps his arms around you
and bite your lip it's literally he's
that you know where we always if you're
in that kind of a bar fight and you
would bite right here right above the
eyebrow cuz that just opens up and blood
yeah very very soft yeah and you bite
and blood comes out and the whole fights
over I'd be scared to get my teeth
knocked out with a headbutt throat up
getting that close I would go for the
nose fight the nose yeah that's the old
wrestling trick to bust him open right
above the eyebrow right Yeah right
cuz it's easy to break the skin and it
blue they also would go high on the
forehead too right that's where they cut
yeah yeah like if they were gonna do it
like they were gonna hit you to bust you
open it would be the eyebrow and then if
you were gonna cut yourself with a razor
blade then it so is that the hard way or
is our land like when they do the
eyebrow it'd be playing I may be hard
way but it'd be planned how would they
crowd they just know they're gonna hit
you hard enough to open you up yeah yeah
we're gonna do it hard way that would be
what it was called nothing they would
just hit you down there's this clip from
would hate that WrestleMania 20 I think
where Mick Foley is trying to get Randy
Orton to do it to him and Randy's like a
young guy so he didn't grow up in an era
when that was happening cuz it makes you
didn't open the hard way oh my god but
in this clip like it's not working
Randy's not hitting him in the right
spot yeah so you're just watching Mick
Foley just just get hit in the head over
and over again hmm with like just these
blunt like why isn't he busting open
hits
I'd rather blade didn't have somebody
play a [ __ ] face like oh yeah
absolutely
but Mick's been open hard way a few
times he had an open hard way yeah well
once you've you've done that stuff to
your head then it'll start to happen
right away anyway scars like Flair his
just start bleeding even for no apparent
reason every match just thinking Dusty
Rhodes would do it here like is his
forehead by the end of it look like
chopping
well when you're up close with those
guys it's really horrific looking yeah I
haven't seen any of them up close
I haven't looked yeah once you know yeah
look at that photo the third photo in
yeah oh wow like that's look at that you
know I mean and that's that's from years
of every single night doing it yeah
thank you tell a wrestler and he could
tell him a jiu-jitsu guy by his ears
exactly yeah the cauliflower yeah now
the some of those guys will let somebody
else open him up yeah [ __ ] that
yeah myself he said when stone cold and
Bret Hart wrestled stone cold had Brett
open him up which you're never really
supposed to do what contrasted him
Austin trusted him yeah yeah how would
he open them up like take a razor blade
out and cut him
thank you most of the time you guys
their fingers they keep a little tiny
razor blade in there at a certain point
and then just go like this across the
forehead and that blood will open and
they keep it in their hand the whole
time yeah they did well they keep it in
their tape so it'd be in their wrist
tape or in their finger tape or whatever
it is would be like a little sliver of a
razor blade having that could hurt doing
that they wrap it in tape and then they
put the blade on top and then they wrap
that into you but a lot of times it'll
just chuck it on the mat and the referee
has to go pick it up and put in his
pocket or something yeah yeah yeah
that's how you do that on tape or
they'll use it they'll just throw it man
and then yeah tough guys
oh yeah it's unbelievable yeah what they
put themselves through we we used to do
wrestling stuff like with the
independent league and then some WWE
[ __ ] stuff and so they go oh come in
and train and you're like okay now how
do I do that with a you know without it
hurting there go it's gonna hurt yeah
but here's how you do it yeah so you
don't get injured but it's gonna hurt
every time I'm like but how do you do
the thing with the slaps in the chest oh
no it hurt the heart right you just
[ __ ] hurts like when people try to
figure out like how do they whip each
other when they still when they whip
each other with the belt and then those
welts start to show up on the back how
do you do that Wow you take about the
belt off your pants when you whip
someone with it you know what really
[ __ ] hurts is going off the ropes
oh yeah [ __ ] ropes have are just like
metal with a little rubber so you like
you like oh I'm in the rim and a bounce
off the ropes and we [ __ ] you see you
see like the new guys somehow your body
just adjust to it and get used to it but
like when you start you can see they end
up with these big like
bleeding bloody like ring rash is what
they call it yeah because they've just
been hitting the ropes right here over
and over there guys that hit the ropes
every match I mean now everybody hits
the ropes every man oh they do yeah I
did a thing cuz we were doing like a
dark match before one of them on things
is because you could say that so like
somebody gave me like a [ __ ] lariat
and you know so my legs go up but I
didn't tuck my head I [ __ ] land and my
head hits the mat so I jump up and does
that thing where you're dizzy and I'm
like I think I'm gonna throw up in front
of 20,000 people and I just had to act
like I was yelling and stuff but I
wasn't even making any noise don't throw
up dude this is a [ __ ] start spitting
amazing if you puked in the ring yeah
quickest way to get it by the way the
dark match happens at the beginning of
the show didn't have the whole
pay-per-view happened with Bennington
puke on them you know it can fight his a
Doug Benson is that right no you can
love you Doug I guess he doesn't split
the money though does it
no no winner winner gets the part that's
the quickest way to get a concussion is
to not know to tuck your chin Tiempo
made a wrestler puke let me see that
so it's headshots and just it just
knocks you completely lay that place is
sold out you can hear it know right now
they didn't show the puke there's like
three people in the audience they've
piped in all this all these crowd sounds
it's just a new CM Punk you know this is
very very old who's who now CM Punk is
in the yellow reject tiled on the floor
and this other guy is just a young indie
guy don't know who he is
oh no literally open mic wrestling right
yeah this is a bringer there's only
other [ __ ] wrestlers and the only
people watching this was it a headshot
that's gotta feel pretty good to make
the other guy puke yeah yeah yeah I've
done that different way
[Laughter]
yes obviously guys puke but a lot of
times - at shows like this guys are
puking because their extracurricular
activities as well not just because
they're getting shots to the head how
does that this this is probably 15 it's
2005 50 almost 15 years old
yeah man that's badass yeah Oh Matt
Sidell is the guy yeah he went on to
also be a big big wrestler you know who
he is
mm-hmm I know I know how a lot of the
guys are let's uh let's go to what we
were gonna go to before let's go to the
update on this who the thirty year old
who got thrown out there guy yeah no it
wouldn't no I think we're different back
then you got that right
the New York Post went and found him in
the Airbnb that he's living in in
Syracuse and they caught up with him
yeah the news had a field day with him
they did they loved you know because he
became the guy that you can bully and
get away with it so everybody on the
news was like oh these Millennials
you're so lazy but you know what I mean
Oh trust me he deserved it but but you
know who I blame on this blame the
parents me to their [ __ ]
responsibility they brought this into
the world if you have a [ __ ]
special-needs kid you have to take care
of him forever you can't go he's 18 now
right I took him on this [ __ ] kick
can't handle himself it shouldn't be our
responsibility any parent I don't know
Ron that's a little cold-hearted I just
then why sue him just kick him out right
any parent that has so little he's gonna
what my dad would kick my ass right
they've got so little respect from their
kid did they have to take him to court
the government has to get involved
destroy the total failure and he was
[ __ ] Boonton and he had a talk-show
confused on that one Ron yeah yeah
that's cool [ __ ] Jeff knows both
yeah that podcast that one pays yes
$2,000 oh wow I don't even making a big
deal about this but you really didn't
get paid that night under bucks yeah yes
that's the whole door hmm you got all of
it bringing back memories from other
radio shows now yes we're getting paid
well you weren't not a dime oh you're on
a lot yeah Vic Henley bought a house d
sub1 no I don't know where he is
let's go back to doing just fine yeah
yeah it's a hit
let's go back to Michael rotondo Michael
Rotundo to move out of his parents New
York home he looks like a Hasidic Jew he
does the 30 year old and made
international news oh my god this air
B&B was dummy music yeah well I think
that they're trying to portray him as a
Daniel oh yeah panting I love he just
keeps doing interviews he won't say no
to media won't stop every time the media
is like hey look at idiot over here like
howl drema said oh well I moved out with
my parents house yeah drop a fence yeah
put on my fancy can stay here for
nothing all right
[ __ ] you need a [ __ ]
it's a you propose emotions change to
stay here yeah Michael now spends his
days working on his discrimination
lawsuit against best by his former
employer absolutely yeah
which he should what's the
discrimination they'll get to it uh-huh
oh yeah is he black no he is not his
natural son that he had a that he had
out of wedlock oh no I had to add that
in that he odd that that's always live
face yeah he's a Dick Tracy villain with
his former flame so though though the
woman has the kid shirt which she
probably should get a part-time job
somewhere yeah anybody would think he's
an ass he makes sense yeah and I do like
to that he's like hey here's the plan
well build this fence until they kick me
out but in the meantime I'll get my four
hundred thousand from Best Buy
and then I'll be set for life I buy a
house for whatever Cecily Baltic Avenue
do you think that's why it was fired
because yes I buy a great employee
because discrimination is a single male
parent yeah no I don't think so is cuz
he got caught playing Dungeons & Dragons
there for my kid they're all out of the
box
[Music]
hey nuts to you I don't think my
relationship with my parents will ever
really be mended I hope they're happy
with that yeah yeah hey as his bike well
good yeah it looks cool his jumper the
curb since December Wow hey man this
guy's been making his own food for the
last seven months yeah so don't make
jokes he's 30 no this is the state force
in the where that huh Mike for the store
and then leaves the helmet and by the
way the strap is the chinstrap is still
attention straps he leaves his helmet on
Wally's food shopping
one is the hold this [ __ ] gel
together why didn't you get a job as a
grocery bagger it's not a bad idea right
you probably pick up some decent money
buy a [ __ ] house for 15,000 for 600
he's like Daniel Carlin with money
yeah he's [ __ ] Rain Man he has no
idea how much stuff costs I'll bet if
the grocery store went to him and it's
like we'll give you $15 a week if you
work every day really yeah I'll take
that job somebody about that reality
show you can see I know and I'm gonna
watch it every week piss you know
they're not wrong a reality show yeah he
tries to uh he's just going up to
strangers and asking him about
bullying's
yeah maybe makes a good bouillabaisse
you know this kid is making a full
breakfast every day for himself that's
right this kid is like that cute kid and
Forrest Gump at the end of the movies
you're all dumb short hair yeah [ __ ]
aids do Robin Wright Penn you know
[ __ ] Michael chase it's up to me
about that movie I'll never forget he
goes what if it was the other way and
this [ __ ] guy just kept coming back
and having sex with a [ __ ] girl yeah
you know what I mean like when you're
thinking about yeah what the [ __ ] was
Robin Wright thinking in that movie but
she didn't want here's the thing Forrest
hung out with her all that time she
didn't want to [ __ ] him she finally did
who they were friends
childhood so she finally threw the big
dope a little puss I see yeah then she
went out and caught the heavens I want
you moving stupid right nobody treated
her well except yeah Danny guy yeah
what's that what is wrong for us was it
Down syndrome
yeah it was something she hated this bag
he was always running and it ball smells
yeah by the way this would be perfect
for sure see where his mom [ __ ] that
super intent of the principle that was
heavy
yeah and hot strange children's movie
yeah I really was let's go back to Mike
was browning me to you I hate this guy
it's terrible isn't it supposed to I
think he's kind of cool chicken I'm
gonna put it back on the same surface
why he's great he's gonna get sick and
die of course you do why are you taking
so [ __ ] we'll make just shitty food
what the hell is wrong with him I
couldn't do what he just did not good
neither would you probably put the
chicken back on the uncooked chicken
surface yes but I can pay eat off that
plate oh it's all the chicken juice on
it yeah we're trained to chicken juice
good boy you're so hardcore man I like
it I shake it crazy if you chill it in
the fridge for two hours then you drink
your [ __ ] chilled chicken juice is it
good
yeah and that way you don't have to go
to school tomorrow I gave myself a [ __ ]
you
if that hadn't happened I would have a
really good job with them as an
assistant manager I could have made them
a lot of money I could have been best
buy a lot of money he could have brought
a lot of money into best chain now why
did they fire him they're dumb company
then to not see this guy's potential it
was discrimination because he's a single
male pattern there's no custody of his
kid that's right yeah it doesn't matter
he's still a good employee but I do make
fun of people that have kids like what's
with you you know you belong here with
the rest of us oh you do yeah it's my
thing who [ __ ] this guy
yeah that's Mellie got to see her that's
really the biggest failure of all is
[ __ ] Forrest Gump
I disagree now you think he's got
something I think he's probably good
employee he would have made them a lot
of money while I like that he said that
not only did they fire him if they
invited me and also failed to promote me
all right you know they would promote it
would discriminate by everyone but yeah
it'll go to Best Buy now because of this
yes bye I could watch people this
delusional all day though for employees
an entire $3,000 my friend show that you
can hopefully get on your own well Alex
at least we know that Alex was not
acting selfishly Alex saw the potential
hey there's no Doug Benson I'll tell you
that right now bring a gift you got
someplace to be Jimmy industry yes way
of doing oh really
right
city of the Angels la-la-land
I say both of those things during the
flight yeah look if you get this [ __ ]
movie everything changes for you I know
it could be it I know it could be really
really big I hope so
yeah what do you put what are you
auditioning for yeah what's the role
it's the sequel to kim gitae let's go
back he was saying that the his 3,000
from Alex Jones he's gonna keep him
above water until he gets his 400,000
from best ROI lawsuits ironed out so
he's all he's all set yeah so I think
Michaels been [ __ ] - giving her a
[ __ ] box full of hogs
yeah that chickens not the only thing
Michael paces around with his stick not
at all Michael comes in with onion
breath and gives her a [ __ ] box full
of hog only can't have another kid yeah
it's funny doesn't bear any looks like
my landlord so you get bothered when you
see people like that yes because the
attention he's getting in and yeah the
people are just handing the money what a
mooch yeah yeah you'd love three grand
just ain't the same way when I see
somebody in a wheelchair say what you
want to get in trouble why can't I say
country why do you.why yelling nickels
so everybody know wheelchairs gotta
overcome something come on just exactly
a [ __ ] pub it's always like
rollerball or you know the plain sports
yeah get out of here enjoy the downtime
yeah I wonder I watch this for the stock
market open 2930 mm-hmm as Best Buy
plummeted Travis can you check that as
Best Buy plummeted since this story came
out because this was I saw this for the
first time last night yeah so I'm
assuming that maybe now that trading has
begun Best Buy is gonna be in a lot of
trouble
looks like Travis is looking up it went
up
see went up without him okay Rob you
just checked we're anticipating Best Buy
is Best Buy's actually up Sirius is down
Best Buy is up no I guess we should have
been talking about this kid after
talking about it yeah the drought this